that this is our land we will be
defending it
if they had crossed that border what do
you think the west would have done for
you
our judicial system is in bad shape
america's secretary of state anthony
blinken was in ukraine last week
his aim apparently to offer words of
comfort and support to the country
after russian troops had massed in huge
numbers close to its border
my guest this week from kiev is
ukraine's foreign minister dimitro
kuleba
what did he get out of the visit and
what was he asked to give
dimitro cool labor welcome to conflict
zone
good afternoon the u.s secretary of
state was
visiting kiev last week and
said he stands strongly with your
country
what do you understand that to mean
standing strongly with you
that means uh political uh
me and military and uh reforms
uh uh support for ukraine
we count on our partnership with the
united states
as much as we count on the partnership
with the european union and its key
capitals
your president was clear that he wanted
more than that a few days before
blinken arrived he posted a tweet
calling for
a clear signal about the european and
euro atlantic prospect
in other words a clear signal about your
bid for membership of the eu and nato
did you get that clear signal well uh
both uh perspectives uh uh of
euro-atlantic and
uh european membership are long overdue
uh i would like to recall that for
example when it comes to nato
the promise was given by allies uh in
2008
at bucharest summit so we've been it's
been
13 years now and my president reiterates
the
ambition uh to achieve that uh
we have not heard uh affirmative uh
positive response
yet but uh this is uh you know we are
aspirants we are seeking membership so
we will keep
pushing this story forward so you didn't
get what you wanted so in effect
mr blinken just bought a basket of fine
words and
that was it no
uh it would be uh not entirely correct
mr blinking was there not entirely but
there's some truth to it
well uh he did not bring with himself a
promise
uh that ukraine will become a member of
nato uh this year or next year
but uh he uh reaffirmed that the united
states
stand by the decision of 2008 where it
says clearly
uh ukraine and georgia because it
applied to both countries
will be members of nato and we will be
working with
our friends and partners on achieving
this goal but the problem is without a
timetable it's meaningless isn't it
uh well uh what we need we currently
have a timetable
which is called uh annual
program of cooperation between ukraine
and nato
it is structured very much along the
pattern of
the membership action plan but what we
do need and i can agree with you here
is uh a clear uh timeline
of uh granting ukraine membership action
plan
and what will follow after that this is
the next step
in our uh integration with the alliance
how far did you get with your shopping
list because you're known to be looking
for enhanced
anti-drone and anti-aircraft
capabilities
you also want the patriot missile is
washington
going to meet those requests well we
did submit to the united states a list
of the most urgent needs for ukrainian
army
some of the items on the list are more
easier to get some are more difficult
we do not expect to get everything at a
time but we are making progress on those
items and on those positions which uh
which are feasible at this at this point
you say you're making progress so you
didn't get any of them
you haven't signed any deals to get them
it's not it's not
fixed uh mr m secretary blinken did not
bring
an anti-sniper complex with him but
uh uh no no that he was going to give
you one
either nor a date i have no doubts that
we will we will receive
a number of items from our list this
does not require a reiteration it's a
matter of cooperation of certain
technicalities
but i have no doubts that we will get
them mr
labour let's talk if we may about the
frozen war in the
eastern part of your country if we can
talk about it that way
there's been some de-escalation in
tension
with moscow it withdrew many of its
troops after their
sudden and massive deployment close to
your joint border
if they had crossed that border what do
you think the west would have done for
you
expressions of condemnation maybe some
sanctions
well first uh there is no
uh withdrawal adequate
to the number of russian troops
and military machinery assembled along
the border of ukraine and in the
occupied territories what is happening
cannot be called a withdrawal
russian forces largely stay where they
are
what has changed is a drop in military
rhetorics
this is true but the threat is still
there
and you know in the soviet union they
had
show trials trials without justice and
now what we observe
is a show withdrawal a withdrawal
without removal of forces and this we
should be
we should be we should remain vigilant
on this when it comes to your second
question it is this is our land
these are our people we will defend it
we will fight for it we do not expect
foreign troops to arrive and help us
but we do expect from partners to
provide ukraine with
all assistance they can
offer to make us prevail
in this struggle for our country so
you're not expecting
nato to go to war with you um with
russia
you're clear on that to defend you
uh absolutely we are not a member of
nato
yet and i would like to uh say
again clearly and squarely that this is
our land
we will be defending it but partners can
help us
to defend our land and i'm sure that
this is what will this will be happening
when it comes to negotiations your
president has made it clear he no longer
thinks the
minsk two agreement has laid down six
years ago
is the way forward is that because
neither you
nor the russians nor the separatists
have actually done what you signed up to
do
uh well the the key
demand of russia in minsk
is to recognize uh so-called lugansk and
doneness people's republic
as party to the conflict which would
effectively
uh turn an international armed conflict
between ukraine and
russia into an internal armed conflict
between ukraine
and separatists this is the cornerstone
of the discussions that are taking place
in in minsk now my president is saying
that our goal number one
should be peace and security and lives
of people
and not the political political
recognitions and we call on
moscow to focus on the same on bringing
peace
to donbass and on making progress on a
number of draft decisions which are
ready to be adopted
they're pending green light from moscow
moscow can easily give that green light
but it continues playing this game with
the
demand to recognize donetsk and lugansk
as part of
the conflict so this is in essence what
is happening in minsk and this is why
we are making steps to ensure
a way forward out of this stalemate the
minst ii
agreement as you know contained
political commitments
on you uh and on the other side article
four a dialogue on local elections was
supposed to start
the day after heavy weapons were pulled
back from the contact line
article 11 a new ukrainian constitution
should have entered into force by the
end of 2015
its key element was to have been
decentralization
none of these things happened did they
and each side blames the other
for not fulfilling their side of the
bargain where do you go from here
uh you are absolutely right uh this is
this is
the word to word by word russian
narrative about
minsk when moscow omits the fact
that item paragraph one of minsk is
security
first you stop shooting and then you
proceed to political settlement
ukraine uh spared no effort and made a
number of painful concessions to ensure
a ceasefire
unfortunately the ceasefire has been
violated on a systemic basis and more
and more and many ukrainian
soldiers had been killed uh i would like
to
assure you that we are absolutely
committed to moving along the political
uh part of the uh of the minsk
uh of the minsk agreements you really
think you could get those through
security first do you think you could
get those through your parliament
those political aspects of the minster
agreement
well if we see if we see that russia is
uh not killing our soldiers is
withdrawing its heavy
machine heavy military machinery from
ukraine and that it abides
by security provisions this will give us
an additional argument
in the parliament to convince that this
is the road
to the to peace this is the road to
settlement and this is what my
parliament wants
but we will never accept any russian
idea of uh
federalization of ukraine because uh
in in in this country we have a very
advanced reform of decentralization and
by the way i would like to thank the
government of germany
in helping us with this reform to really
empower communities on the ground and to
give them more right
rights and when uh certain regions of
donetsk and lugansk
parts of ukraine which are currently
occupied by russia return
to ukraine they will enjoy all those
vast possibilities for
development and prosperity yeah but why
does your president say he's not going
to talk to them russia says talk to the
separatists your president refuses
um i'm curious as to why he refuses
because the people in
donetsk and lukansk are still ukrainian
citizens aren't they
why is your president refusing to talk
to ukrainians
if he wants that area back under his
control
my president will talk to legitimately
elected ukrainians in the currently
occupied parts of donetsk and lugansk we
will not
talk to holders of russian passports
who vigorously and duly implement
only instructions coming from moscow uh
they we should not mix these two
categories up
uh when we hold elections as provided by
the minsk agreements when there are
legitimately elected
representatives they will be
become part of the political system and
we will talk
uh to them but today the only party that
makes decisions
and instructs people on the ground how
to act
is moscow it's not this so-called
separatists
yes but this process is going nowhere
isn't it and the fact is that
you're out of ideas for how to pursue it
something that the president's
chief of staff actually admitted at the
end of last month andre
yermack on television he said it's
necessary to continue working
in all directions and in all formats
because in the end we don't know what
format
will bring peace to our land seven years
after the seizure of crimea that's an
extraordinary
admission of both failure and despair
isn't it you don't know
how to continue uh there is no
faith neither failure nor despair in
kiev
we have
well we are upset with the behavior of
moscow with its unwillingness to
play constructively and to reciprocate
uh
sincere willingness of ukraine and of
germany and france to put an
end to the war in donbas uh when it
comes to crimea
uh you know we launched we came up with
a very good idea
of a crimea platform and this idea this
initiative is gathering more and more
international support
so no we are not running out of ideas
but
unfortunately russia has adopted a very
uh very unhelpful tactics of
uh simply uh downplaying every any idea
that
they do not like or ignoring them but we
will keep trying because as i said just
a couple of minutes before this is our
land we cannot
sit down with our and lay down our hands
we we have to come up we have with new
ideas we have to be creative and we will
be doing that this is our land and it
may take some time but in the end we
will succeed
the fact is that your president was
elected two years ago on a promise to
end the war in the donbass region he
didn't do it
he even blamed the continuing conflict
on his predecessor president poroshenko
saying it wasn't russian aggression that
was the problem it was the ukrainian
side being unreasonable that came back
to bite him as well didn't it
in effect he's over promised and under
delivered
that's the biggest sin a politician can
commit isn't it
well my president still has a couple of
years in office to deliver on that and
uh
to before the end of his first term uh
the second point is that
uh in just first year of his presidency
uh there were some very good
achievements in our relations with
russia and they were promising
for example the exchange of prisoners
including the return of the famous
director or ole exinso
who was a political prisoner in russia
russia returned
our vessels captured at the kirch trade
so there was a good period now there is
a bad period but it doesn't mean that
we will not find a solution
that will bring back the good period and
we will find we will settle the conflict
without crossing our red lines
mr cru labor it's clear that if you want
more help from washington and the west
you're going to have to do more
to deal with the rampant political
corruption in your
country aren't you the state department
says that's key
to securing ukraine's democratic
institutions its economic prosperity and
euro-atlantic future
every year the same message from the u.s
from europe year after year why are you
not doing better on this front
well first we are doing it for ourselves
not for
the sake of uh support but you're not
doing it at all are you
doing you're not doing it at all you're
not getting to grips with corruption
well you are in your country you are
you are you are sir you are either
misinformed or
exaggerating uh it was uh
under the president of uh under the
president zelensky
that the anti-corruption court finally
started functioning in ukraine and it
was a very long battle
to set up that court and make it
operational unfortunately the previous
president did not
allow that to happen president zilenski
did and he does not interfere
in the operations of the court when the
constitutional court of ukraine another
body of our judicial system
tried to destroy an anti-corruption
reform it was
the president who stepped in immediately
and
then he was followed by the government
and the parliament
who restored parts of critical
legislation that was declared new
and void now and void by by the
constitutional court
things are happening and you know every
country
is is a difficult combination of various
factors
but this country is moving in the right
direction and those who are calling on
us to move faster
they're accordingly invited to come and
join us and help us that's easy
well those who are you you're cordially
inviting were those who were there last
week if you look at the
state department human rights report the
latest one what
what's clear is that what's damaging
western confidence in you is this
continual drum beat of human rights
abuses that are reported in your country
as pointed out in the latest human
rights report from washington
the concern that's highlighted is not
just the abuse
that or the corruption the abuse or
torture that's carried out by state
employees in your
security service that's bad enough but
the impunity
that surrounds them the fact they can
violate the law with a pretty strong
assurance
that they'll get away with it are you
happy about that
when it comes to human rights abuses in
security institutions
you know uh this is something that is
uh not just neither systemic nor large
scale
and unfortunately to my deepest regrets
present
not only in ukraine but also in other
countries of europe
we follow recommendations of the
european community against torture
on that and we enjoy excellent
cooperation with them
otherwise i do not understand what kind
of systemic violations of human rights
you are referring to well it's quite
clear in the report the report says
abuse of detainees remains
a widespread problem the government
generally
failed to take adequate steps to
prosecute or punish
most officials who committed abuses most
officials
resulting in a climate of impunity that
couldn't be clearer could it that's from
your friends in washington
uh you are probably you are referring to
the situation in prisons with regard to
the imprisoned uh imprisoned persons
this is a big scorch uh not only for
ukraine but also for
other european countries but
this is not a large scale
systemic oppression of human rights
happening
across the country as i said to you
answering my previous question
we are absolutely cooperating with all
human rights bodies including the
council of europe and the european union
to address outstanding issues related to
the treatment of prisoners
in uh in prisons one of the other
key issues which has been raised by
washington is the
low level of confidence reported in your
judges
the u.s says that despite efforts to
reform the judiciary and the prosecutor
general's office
corruption among judges and prosecutors
remained endemic endemic
why is it that you're absolutely why is
it that you're
effectively unable to guarantee the rule
of law in your country
uh well first uh rule of law and
judiciary
uh is not the same thing judiciary is
part of the rule of law and there is a
rule of law in this country
but uh the one of the what its weakest
point that
requires uh uh systemic attention is
judiciary
our judicial system is in bad shape
i can fully agree with that it's uh i i
as a citizen i regret it
and the president and the government
and the parliament they are all
addressing this issue
in close cooperation with our
international partners and the venice
commission of the council of europe
because we all realize that judiciary
is uh an essential important element for
uh foreign investments and for bringing
also for for bringing justice to the
country
for protecting human rights in the
country so
we are addressing it uh this this
problem through a set of reforms
conducted in the closest possible
cooperation
with uh international institutions and
international partners
the state department says some judges
were pressured by
high-level politicians others reportedly
took
bribes in exchange for giving particular
verdicts
if they're found to be breaking the law
like that why can't they be removed from
office
i'm not aware of any report that a
member of the government or the
president's office would be
pressuring uh pressuring
a judiciary in a court or a judge
quite to the contrary some of the
uh elements of the ukrainian judiciary
are putting pressure on the government
and uh by issuing an
ill legitimate judgments uh
in particular the one that i mentioned
the judgment of the constitutional court
that tried to destroy the
anti-corruption reform
that was designed and
implemented by ukraine and its friends
and partners from abroad
but i'm sure that we will overcome this
problem as well because
no corrupt judge can succeed
against the government and the people of
ukraine that are willing
to overcome to resolve and overcome this
problem
what about the press journalists too are
feeling the heat in your country when
they deal with sensitive topics
washington says violence against the
press remained the problem
with human rights groups blaming
government in action in solving crimes
against them why this inaction on the
part of the government
well the problem of press should be
considered from two sides
on the one side it's the problem of
disinformation flowing
into the country and spreading around
among among citizens this is something
that the government should be addressing
and is addressing
to ensure security of the country on the
other hand
we do have to ensure the freedom of
speech and we are absolutely committed
to it
and of course to ensure safety of
journalists uh
i'm not aware of any recent cases where
a government agent or representative or
someone associated with the government
would be
conducting uh would be suppressing
freedom of speech
in fact the criticism
against the president the parliament the
government as a whole
is uh coming from many many media
corners and that's normal because we
live in a democracy
and it's it's vibrant and there are many
different opinions
all these can uh can ex can and should
exist in a free democratic country
however we will not allow uh
this information specifically coming
from russian media
to destroy
our people's people's minds yes the
question is also to what extent you're
protecting your journalists because
the state department report mentioned a
journalist from hramatsuke who was
beaten by a police officer
while he was filming protests in front
of a government building that was april
last year
seven months later the state bureau of
investigations was still
quote looking into it is that good
enough as far as you're concerned
well if we start picking up one specific
case
and focus on it of course the situation
will look doom and gloom
i uh i'm where i'm aware of this case i
find it
uh uh disturbing as well and i stand on
the
on the side of a journalist in this
particular case but please do not try to
create
a picture of doom doom and gloom picture
based on i'm not creating any
specific cases taking out taking out of
the context now we are in
a dialogue with you i'm just trying to
make the point yes i'm not creating any
any image that hasn't been reflected in
the
state department human rights report
just one final question you talk about
how you're
protecting your country and um
you talk about getting your land back
do you seriously imagine a day when the
russians will say to you sorry we took
crimea
big mistake have it back or has that
train left the station
well did you imagine that the soviet
union
one day would seriously say eastern
germany can go back to germany and
reunite
again i'm sure that if your leadership
and your politicians
never imagined that they would never
succeed
minister kulaiba it's been a pleasure
having you on conflict zone thank you
very much
thank you
[Music]
you